the movie might feature a rampaging bear
on drugs but the story of the real
cocaine bear might be even crazier
here's what happened to the bear once
called Pablo Escobar in November of 2022
a new poster for a cocaine bear dropped
on Twitter giving viewers their first
look at its titular character posting
perhaps the most self-explanatory movie
titles since Snakes on a Plane the
Elizabeth Banks directed Thriller tells
the story of a bear that goes on a
rampage after ingesting a large supply
of cocaine from a drug runner's crashed
plane over the course of its run time
the film follows several people
converging on a nearby town as they
attempt to escape or subdue the coked up
Beast
the bear it did cocaine while
cocaine bear features a cast that
includes Kerry Russell Margo Martindale
and the late Ray Liotta in his final
role it's safe to say that this is a
movie that nevertheless hopes to draw
viewers in on the sheer absurdity of its
premise first and foremost it's perhaps
all the more surprising then that
cocaine bear really is based on true
events as detailed on its first poster
in fact not only is the real life story
still in the cultural Zeitgeist decades
after it happened but the actual bear is
still out in the world to this day in a
sense the story behind the bear that
inspired the rampaging movie slasher
isn't as Sensational as some might think
rather the cocaine Bears brief history
is more sad than thrilling according to
the Louisville Courier Journal the true
story began in 1985 when a Narcotics
officer turned drug Smuggler Andrew
Thornton fell from a plane who was
flying over Knoxville Tennessee among
the items in Thorne's possession was
around 75 pounds of cocaine some of
which was ingested by a 175 pound black
bear that happened upon the plane's
wreckage the bear sadly died as would
happen to any creature that manages to
eat several pounds of cocaine regardless
of ferocity a medical examiner found
that the poor thing showed signs of a
range of Health complications from
cerebral hemorrhaging to heart failure
to respiratory failure after its cause
of death was determined the lay Bear's
body was taxidermied and bounced around
between various owners including country
Legend Waylon Jennings today cocaine
Bears home is among various Oddities at
the Kentucky for Kentucky fun Mall in
Lexington according to owners he still
attracts a large number of visitors
interested in his Sensational albeit
somewhat tragic story
we have the cocaine bear on display at
the Kentucky for Kentucky fund Mall the
Kentucky 4 Kentucky fun mall where the
Taxidermy cocaine bear currently resides
isn't a mall in the traditional sense
rather it's more of a hybrid gift shop
and tourist attraction selling Kentucky
themed goods and as outlined in a
mission statement on the Kentucky for
Kentucky website promoting its home
State's past and present history the
store also sells a wide range of cocaine
bear merchandise to the extent that its
webpage dedicates an entire tab to its
cocaine bear merch page in fact and
living good who helps run the Kentucky
for Kentucky fund Mall told Inside
Edition that she believes their
acquisition of the real bear was largely
responsible for his present-day
notoriety previously she explained the
bear bounce between owners whereas
Kentucky for Kentucky made him the focus
of an exhibit dedicated to circulating
his story in as much detail and among as
wide of an audience as possible so while
his fictional counterpart is terrorizing
innocent humans on this Silver Screen
those interested in the Bear's history
can join the many tourists who make it a
point to see cocaine Bear In the Flesh
at his present day Kentucky home
[Music]